hello winner how are you feeling
oh i'm just i just can't come down from
this like i don't know if i ever will
i was just joking on my social media
everyone's like where are you gonna put
the mirror ball and i'm like
depends what room i'm in i'll take it
everywhere with me i'm gonna put nothing
down is it in the bed with you at this
point you must just be like laying with
it
i usually i didn't actually bring it
into the room last night right now it's
right here
in my office behind me yeah so
wherever i am it will be oh my gosh okay
what went through your mind when they
called your name
i mean uh honestly a little bit of
disbelief
because i truly thought neve was gonna
win i don't know
i'm usually a very like i manifest i say
it out loud i
think it i feel it and i was doing that
all day and
while i was standing there and i'm that
pause that tyra did was the longest
pause in tv history
and as i'm standing there i just kept
hearing her say nev and i'm like oh no
this
i'm like caitlyn be more positive and i
had enough time to really think about
what name she was going to say and so
when i heard her say
caitlin and artem i just honestly like
my
it felt out of body like i felt like i
had an out of body experience and i just
like
i watch it back and i'm dying because i
i forgot i was
miked and i was screaming and like like
not a cute like
it was like like screaming so happy it
was just pure joy
yeah and we all felt it too watching it
like we all got the chills and we all
like i got misty-eyed i mean i think we
all felt pretty connected to you this
season
you went through so much i mean from
injuries to trolls
you know respecting me to carry on and
ava
you went through a lot so what does it
mean to win at this point
yeah that was i mean i wouldn't want a
journey like that that is
it's literally a dream for me i've
thought about being on the show for five
years it's something that i've always
wanted i've been a fan of the show for
so many years
um dancing has is just such a passion of
mine like it just makes me so happy
that i wouldn't want a journey to be
easy peasy breezy floating through it
and then win at the end like it means so
much
more when you can look back on your
three months there and be like i
was grinding i was in that studio every
day
seven days a week no days off six hours
a day
we like walked in and it wasn't like we
didn't take a lunch break we were
in it to win it and coming back from
like an ankle injury thinking i wasn't
gonna dance like everything just makes
it that much sweeter yeah and your
mother was a dance teacher
what was her reaction when you won i
think she thought she won the mirror
ball
i mean she was bawling
her eyes out like like
shaking balling just so so happy because
you know she she worked her whole life
as a dancer ballet and tap and she was
so incredible
and she ended up retiring and you know
starting a family and she just knows
the the hard work that's put on into
that and i don't think a lot of people
see at home like really how much
work and time and effort goes into it
but
i think she knew she'd been on the phone
with me when i'd come home in tears
or when i was just loving every second
like she really was on that whole
whole ride with me so she she was very
happy
ah proud and supportive that's so sweet
um this was a big time uh for artem as
well
obviously yeah new baby first time
winning i mean that must have been
really incredible for him to have this
moment um
what does it mean for you to be a part
of that and the reason that he had this
amazing year as well
a part of me was almost happier for
artem
because i mean that guy deserves
everything he he really puts his heart
and soul
and and just everything into dance when
he's there
and i know that was really hard because
when you have a newborn baby at home
and you're gone like all he wanted to do
was put his son to bed
and be there when he woke up in the
morning and all these like new little
things
and having nikki at home like it's
coveted so they don't have like
help and i just feel like
it he just really wanted that and he
wanted to do it for his son
and for his fiance and and he did and i
i just saw how much it meant to him at
the end and i was
like when i saw artem get emotional i
was like
like it just it and the fact was five
years ago when i was supposed to be on
the show he was supposed to be my
partner
and we both we both talked about this
and we're like
we just both weren't in a good place in
our lives to like be on tv
and be like in the right headspace that
now five years later
timing is crazy and the universe works
in such funny ways
and for us to be partners five years
later and to win like
it just meant so much to both of us yeah
and with everything that you guys have
gone through this season
um was it worth it now that you have won
do you feel like it was all worth it
yes i would i would do it all over again
the exact same
way it's it you know it just
it just means so much more when you go
through something with someone
and having you know jason to come home
to when he
and nikki like we are and i talked about
it we were so lucky to have a support
system at home that like
they didn't make us feel bad for
anything like it wasn't like oh my gosh
we
really got like they had you know dinner
on the table or they were happy to see
us or staying up to wait for us and
and just having that to share to share
this with and to come home and know like
if i'm crying one day or if i'm sore or
if i can't even move because my
ribs were hurting like to have somebody
so supportive take care of you and then
win it's just like
i don't know it's i like when things are
challenging and you get a good outcome
from it
yeah i heard that
jason said he wouldn't propose if you
didn't
win i know he was joking is the pressure
on now you know christmas is coming we
got a mirror ball
that's funny yeah i don't know i i know
he doesn't
feel pressure um i'm i'm just not
i'm not really the kind of person that's
like put a ring on it i
joke about that but i'm like whenever
you're ready like whenever we're ready
whenever the time is right i just i want
to be surprised
um so i'm like i just said about an hour
go to somebody i'm like it could happen
tonight it could happen
in like next year it could happen i
don't know i don't know
yeah but um i just keep joking because
everyone you know everyone wants to know
especially coming off the
bachelor world it's like oh you've been
together for a year so
you should probably be engaged and we've
just talked about it where it's like
no rush we know it'll happen and it
again could happen tonight who knows
imagine who knows
who knows oh my god so exciting um with
obviously with
former bachelorettes winning
back-to-back seasons do you think this
like opens the door
for bachelorettes to be on in the future
like is this like a bachelorette's just
winning everything at this point
i know i actually you know that was
something that was going through my head
too where i'm like
would they really have two bachelorettes
win back to back like i don't think so
and i think that was going through my
head
and i just know bachelor nation is so
loyal
the following is just incredible like
they're just
always rooting for people and i truly
believe it's because
you come on that show just like they
would you know you're you're just
a regular person trying to find love and
they really go on this
journey with you and i think that's why
they're just so
loyal after they really want they feel
like they got to know you
um on tv so i
i just thank them so much and especially
bella army they're
a force too like it's because it can't
you know of course the dancing counts
and the hard work and everything that
you put into it but the votes
are what gets you through to each week
so it's yeah
it's really cool and i i mean i will
always be rooting for bachelorettes to
go on that show
i love it um will you be asking carrie
ann and abba on your podcast
yes what a great idea
yes i would love to have all the judges
on my podcast to be honest
um i think that would be a really great
conversation
ah um i know nelly recently made some
comments that you know he wouldn't have
done the show
if he had known people with dancing
experience were participating
um what do you think about that and have
you had a chance to talk to him
um no i i was really disappointed when i
heard him say that i don't know if he
was joking or serious
but i was like nelly one did you did you
really think you were going to come on
the show and just be like uh
i'm going to make it to you know the
mirror ball because i'm a dancer
he's a performer like yeah
oh somebody's outside my door um
oh great just hold on
just wait
i'm so sorry no
this is hilarious i think your dog has
beef with nellie that's the vibe i'm
doing
hey robbie come here
okay sorry um okay i was
i was he's like still growling um
i was really disappointed when nelly
said that because i'm like
it it's a voting show he got
through to the final to the finale um
because because people are rooting for
him
and yeah you know we we all have
something that we bring to the table
when it came to this competition whether
that was
a following who wanted to see us dance
um
he's been a performer for how many years
um you know neve had dance experience
i love to dance i'm trying to think like
other people
had a bigger following than some of us
and so everyone had something that you
know
gave them some sort of some sort of
advantage so when he said that i'm like
what can't you just be happy for people
who like had a dream come true
yeah yeah i feel you girl um but you
still got your mirror ball it's behind
you
hey yeah and i'm still a nelly fan
me too we're both natalie bands um
what's
next for you what's going on in your
life girl uh i don't know
i right now i'm like i
i'm just like i think i have like 800
emails to catch up on
like i i'm just going to focus on i've
got my wine label i have my scrunchie
line
we have so many exciting things coming
up with that and
i i know i'm back in nashville i've been
singing and
and writing music before i left so i'll
probably get back to that and
and just kind of focus on who regrouping
like saving my body resting like
i gotta just relax for a little bit
awesome
well it was so nice to talk to you and
congratulations
thank you so much i appreciate you
you